Hey folks, today we're going to be
talking about top K YouTube videos. This
is a really popular family of problems,
YouTube videos just being one version.
We hear this about Spotify and others
that get asked of across a wide variety
of companies. I would call it a classic
problem that has a lot of different
variants. If you've been following this
channel for long, you might have seen a
previous video about this. Got some
feedback that that video was harder to
follow, so we're going to make this
video more digestible. We're going to
build up kind of from the basics all the
way to the complexities that you might
expect to see in an interview itself.
And along the way, we're going to cover
a lot of really rich topics. Stream
processing, approximation techniques,
count and sketch, time series databases.
The goal here is to try to build up your
toolkit for handling problems like this
because in a lot of cases, the exact
requirements and the exact trajectory
that you're going to follow in the
interview is probably going to be a
little bit different than what we're
covering here. And the goal is either A,
you worked on data-oriented systems and
you've got a better idea for how to
solve problems like this, or you haven't
worked on heavy data processing systems
and you're starting to build some
intuition about how these systems work.
That's the ultimate goal. So, keeping in
mind that you're not trying to memorize
an answer here. You're trying to
understand the concepts so you can apply
them in a variety of different
scenarios.
Now, quick plug on this. I published a
guide for this problem. You can see it
on our website. I'll include a link in
the description. This is basically going
to cover a lot of the same ground that
the video covers. We may touch on a few
topics that aren't covered in the
article, but for the most part, we try
to keep the article up to date with the
video. I won't be able to make any edits
to this video, thanks YouTube. So, you
know, if there's errors or errata, we'll
try to include them in the description.
Now, in the article itself, you can
highlight and make notes. You can add
comments and ask questions. We try to be
active there in answering them or
community is. And there's also a feature
on our website for premium users, which
we call tutor. And what tutor does is we
basically have an AI that allows you to
ask questions about our articles and it
has in its context all of the articles
and all of the insights that we have
across Hello Interview. So, it's going
to be much more informed answering
questions like, "What's Meta's interview
process like?" Or, "What do interviewers
tend to care about?" Then say generic
chat GPT might. Final comment on this,
we have a guided practice for this
problem on our site. A way for us to
work through problems with you with
guidance, and we found this to be
incredibly effective for people who are
especially new to system design
interviews, but also just trying to
knock off some rust before the actual
interview itself. So, we start out by
giving you some requirements, walking
you through our delivery framework,
which I'll talk about in a minute. And
then what you'll see is you're basically
given a whiteboard, just like a real
interview, and ask questions like,
"Let's walk through the non-functional
requirements of the system." I can be
lazy and put just a small number.
Click get feedback, and then shortly
thereafter, I'm going to get a response
from the AI that's going to tell me
about how I did. That's not quite it.
The difference that our guided practice
has from a lot of mock interview
platforms is, first of all, we actually
heavily constrain the AI by looking at
all of the different ways that our users
have gone through difficult problems and
then judging them using staff-level
engineers on the back end so that we can
actually give you good feedback that's
not just generic slop. The other thing
that our guided practice does really
well is it's much better at teaching.
So, it's a really immersive platform for
you practicing for your system design
interviews. Definitely worth checking
out if you have it. But, let's go ahead
and get into top K. Now, when you're in
a system design interview, your
interviewer is probably going to plop
some question, either verbally they're
going to say, "Hey, design top K YouTube
video." Or, they might paste something
on the screen, but usually you are going
to be in the driver's seat for the rest
of the interview. And what we found
through thousands of mock interviews is
that candidates who have some structure
oftentimes have a leg up to candidates
who don't. Because if you just come in
and you've got a lot of thoughts and you
want to get them down, it can be very
hard to get the right pieces over to
your interviewer that they're going to
need for the evaluation. So, we created
what we call our Hello Interview
Delivery Framework. And I'm going to
follow this structure in this video just
as an illustration. The way the
framework works is that we are going to
first set up our problem. We're going to
ask our interviewer lots of questions
about requirements. For top K, this is
really important. We're going to spend a
fair amount of time here. Next, we're
going to get into core entities, which
are really like the nouns of our design.
They aren't as important for top K
problems, but they're really important
for a lot of problems, so we'll go
through it anyway, just so you can see
what it looks like. And then we'll come
up with our API for our system. If you
can think about it, having an API gives
us a way to start the problem. If we can
figure out how to design a system that
satisfies our API, then in some sense
we're done. It's the root of what we
need to build. For some problems, we
will talk about a data flow. We're not
going to talk about it here, but it is
applicable for a lot of back-end
data-oriented systems.
And then next, we're going to go into
our high-level design. This is what
everyone is normally familiar with,
where we're going to be drawing blocks
on the screen. With our high-level
design, we're going to try to design a
system that minimally satisfies our
functional requirements. And the reason
for that is twofold. One, we want to
make sure that we have a working system
by the end of the interview. And if we
start to optimize prematurely, there's a
good chance that we actually won't be
able to get to all of the requirements.
The second thing is that it's oftentimes
much easier to take a working system and
optimize it than to take an optimal
system and make it working. You'll find
this to be especially true of real
production systems, and so it should be
no surprise that it actually applies in
the interview setting. Now, once we have
a working system, then it comes to deep
dives. And these are going to be the
places where we are going to start to
layer on our non-functional
requirements, latency and scaling. This
is also a place where our interviewer
might ask us additional questions. They
might change the game. They might throw
in new requirements. And what we want to
do is leave ample time to be able to go
into these details after we've laid the
foundation of a working high-level
design. And so, that's what we're going
to do with this top K design. Let's
start with requirements. Requirements
can be broken down into two categories,
our functional requirements and our
non-functional requirements. Functional
are really about what our clients see or
what our users are expecting out of the
system. It's kind of the whole reason
the system exists in the first place,
but in many cases, this is determining
what the system needs to be able to do.
The non-functional requirements are more
constraints. They're going to be how it
does that work. And this might be how
the resources are limited, what sort of
data processing is possible. There's a
bunch of things that we can talk about,
but it is really useful for you to
separate this discussion. Now, sometimes
when people hear an infer problem like
top K, they're thinking to themselves,
"Well, the requirements as stated by the
interviewer are pretty complete. They
told me to build a top K system. Let me
go for it." That is absolutely not true.
And you do need to spend time clarifying
these requirements because there's a lot
of ambiguity. And for this problem in
particular, small changes in
requirements imply dramatically
different solutions downstream. We see
this again and again, especially from
candidates who go into an interview and
then are completely flabbergasted that
the interviewer doesn't like their
solution. In many cases, because they
are applying a solution that works for
one set of functional requirements to a
different set of requirements. So,
please take your time here and showcase
your ability to build up the
concreteness of your requirements in the
spec that you're building behind. So,
our interviewer told us to get the top K
most viewed videos. Let's go ahead and
put this down on our requirements so
that we have it. A really good question
for us to ask is, "What time window does
this apply to?" If we build a system
that tries to get the top K all-time
most viewed videos, it's actually not
going to change a lot. I think Gangnam
Style and some Justin Bieber video are
probably near the top and likely aren't
going to change on a day-to-day basis.
It's actually kind of uninteresting. And
so, we might ask our interviewer or make
some assumptions here, but if we ask our
interviewer and say, "Hey, what what
time windows do we want this over?" They
might say, "Well, I want to be able to
do all time. I I'd like to be able to
find Gangnam Style, but I also want to
find the top K most viewed videos over
the last week, month, maybe even day or
hour." This addition of time windows to
the problem adds a lot of interesting
complexity.
It also adds a lot of ambiguity to our
requirements. What do these time windows
actually mean? One example of this is
the difference between what are called
tumbling or sliding windows. So, if I
say last week, for a lot of people, what
that means is the period between Sunday
and Sunday of the prior week.
So, what you see with tumbling windows,
and that's an example of a tumbling
window, is they always start on fixed
boundaries and last for the entire
duration. If someone says last week, you
can assume they're talking about a
tumbling window of weeks.
But, it is possible for them to have
been referring to the last 7-day period
that has just passed. That would be an
example of a sliding window. So, right
now for me, it is Saturday afternoon.
And on Saturday afternoon, a sliding
window of the last 7 days would go from
the prior Saturday at Saturday afternoon
all the way through to the current
period. And that would continue to move
forward. As time advances, that window
moves forward. That 7-day period that
we're talking about changes. So, a good
strategy in an interview setting is to
make an assumption that things are
simple, especially from the functional
requirements, and then run it past your
interviewer.
So, you might say, "I'm going to use
tumbling windows. So, the last month is
going to be the period starting on, you
know, the month start, the first day of
the month, all the way until the end of
the month. Is that okay?" And the
interviewer might go, "Sure. Yeah,
that'll work." I might also clarify that
for week, I'm going to talk about 7
days, and then for month, I'm going to
talk about 28 days. Do I really want to
support calendaring? Absolutely not. So,
we're going to try to simplify things
down here to make our lives a little bit
easier. There are some other problems
that might come out. Like when we say we
want to view all of the videos over the
last month, do we want to be able to
view what happened in October of 2019?
Do we want to be able to support
arbitrary time windows? I'm going to go
ahead and say that this is below the
line. I'm not going to support arbitrary
time windows. This is more of a general
analytics system problem versus a more
specialized system that's calculating
top K. And as such, it's a little less
interesting from an interviewing
perspective, but it's useful for us to
be able to say, "No, this is actually
completely out of scope." We can
continue the conversation here for as
long as we want. Well, I don't think
that you should neglect the
requirements, it's also possible for you
to spend too much time here. And one way
that I find candidates spending too much
time is enumerating a lot of things
below the line, which are basically
things they're not going to be covering
in the interview. So, if you have some
additional time, go ahead and tell your
interviewer, "These are things that I'm
not going to handle." But if not, keep
to your actual in-scope functional
requirements, and then keep moving.
Next, we're going to talk about
non-functional requirements. The
non-functional requirements, like I
mentioned, are the constraints on the
system. They're about how the system
does its work, as opposed to what it's
doing. If you look in our delivery
framework under the non-functional
requirements section, we actually have a
bunch of different categories, which you
can use to start to get your
brainstorming going. But keep in mind,
from an interview perspective, it's
actually more important that you get
useful non-functional requirements than
that you have comprehensiveness.
So, don't memorize this list and then
try to come up with non- one
non-functional requirement for each
category. That's going to be completely
overkill. For this system, it's probably
going to be useful for us to talk about
latency, scale, how the calculations are
actually happening. So, let's go through
those. We'll start with latency, because
everybody likes to talk about latency
for these systems. With our latency,
there's two latencies that we're
concerned with. One is on the right
side. After a view happens,
how does it enter our calculations of
top K? And then we have latency on our
read side. Users make a request, they
want the top K most viewed videos. How
long does that take? On the right side,
there is the reality of distributed
systems is that
a lot of times things will be delayed,
or they'll be out of order at scale. If
you have retries in your system, or if
there is network congestion, or packet
loss, it means things can happen, and
you can learn about them oftentimes
significantly later. So, one
non-functional requirement that's useful
for this problem is to say, "Let's
pretend that we have 1 minute between
when the event happens and when it is
tabulated in our top K." This is going
to be useful for two things. One is if
you're thinking forward, you can imagine
that we're probably going to use some
caching in this system. And the caching
has a TTL. It's basically how long can
we keep around data before it's too
stale to serve to our users. If we set
the cache TTL to be longer than this 1
minute, that means that we're going to
violate this non-functional requirement,
because it means that a view could have
happened, you know, say 1 minute ago,
and we have a cache TTL of 2 minutes,
but we're serving a cache entry that's 2
minutes old. So, we violated this
non-functional requirement. So, in some
sense, this sets an upper bound on our
cache TTLs, which is super useful.
Another thing that it's useful for is
solving that out-of-order problem. If
you have a video view that happened at
9:59 and 59 seconds, but you didn't hear
about it until, say, 10:00 and 6
seconds, you still want to be able to
include it in our top K. We want to make
sure that it shows up. But if that that
video view doesn't appear to us, let's
say, for 3 minutes, maybe it got lost
and put on a truck somewhere, and then
eventually somebody called our service
with it, then we can safely ignore it.
So, what this is basically doing is
giving us a pass to ignore events that
are happening more than 1 minute ago, at
least at the time that we process them,
which is quite useful. The next thing
we'll talk about here is the the read
latency. For systems like this,
interviewers typically want you to be
pretty aggressive. And you can kind of
think about things in three buckets.
The first bucket is like cache hits.
Those are usually single-digit
milliseconds. It can't apply in every
scenario, but it's the best experience
when it can happen, and so single-digit
milliseconds is the gold standard for
distributed systems. The in-between for
for most APIs is something on the order
of tens of milliseconds. Most well-tuned
APIs operate in this vicinity. They
might not in the limit, so they might
have a P99 request that take hundreds of
milliseconds, but tens of milliseconds
is usually a pretty good one. And then
finally, you have search APIs and LLM
APIs that can take hundreds of
milliseconds to seconds, or maybe even
minutes. For this system, we're going to
choose that middle ground. We're going
to say tens of milliseconds for to
retrieve the top K. And this is just
going to give us an idea about what kind
of preprocessing or caching do we need
in order to achieve this aggressive read
latency. Next, I'm going to talk a
little bit about scale. It's useful for
us to think about what dimensions of
scaling are important. And for this
problem, there's two dimensions that are
really important. One is the cardinality
that we need to handle. Cardinality is
like the number of unique items. If
we're calculating the top K of
five items, it's not going to take me
very long at all. I can just sort the
list. If we're calculating the top K of
billions of items, I can't actually do
that sorting in real time. I'm
oftentimes going to need to do some sort
of precomputation. So, for this, I'm
going to assume that I'm handling
billions of videos. I'm going to put a
TBD on this, and basically tell my
interviewer, "I'm going to come back and
refine this estimate a little bit
later." Um but I want them to know that
I'm thinking about the number of videos
that are going to be included, because
it helps me to reason about storage. The
next thing I want to think about is what
kind of write volume do I need the
system to support? And maybe for this,
I'm going to assume hundreds of
thousands of views per second. I'm going
to also put a TBD on this, because I
don't know if hundreds of thousands of
views per second is reasonable for
YouTube.
I might ask the interviewer, "Do you
have a specific number in mind, or
should I try to estimate this?"
Um but I know that this number needs to
be big, and I know that this is going to
be one of the harder things for me to
handle in this particular system. So,
I'm going to go ahead and include it
here. The last non-functional
requirement that I want to address
before we move on is whether I can use
approximation. I'm going to say, "For
this problem, I need precise results, or
no approximation." And the the
justification for this is the same one
that I used in assuming tumbling windows
for this problem. Getting precise
results is often times much easier than
designing a well-set-up
approximate system. Now, I'm going to
walk into one of our deep dives to talk
about approximation and how you might
use it to make an even more scalable
system,
but generally speaking, for interviews,
most of the time, interviewers aren't
expecting you to know about things like
count-min sketch, especially at more
junior levels. And so, being able to say
explicitly in your requirements, "This
is what I need to handle," helps to
clarify that, you know, you're not even
going to consider some of those
solutions. I've got five non-functional
requirements here. I've spent a fair
amount of time. I'm going to go ahead
and stop here. I might ask my
interviewer, "Are there any other things
that I really need to cover in my
requirements, or can I get started?"
And, you know, they're going to give me
the the green light to go ahead. Now
that we've got the requirements stated,
our goal is to get to an API. And the
API is basically the foundation on which
we're going to build our high-level
design. If we've got a set of APIs that
we need to implement, then we can make
sure our system actually implements
those APIs, and if they have, then
they've satisfied our requirements. So,
we're slowly building up toward the
solution. For this problem, the next
step is we're going to establish what
our core entities are. Core entities are
basically nouns that we're going to use
to talk about the problem. For top K,
this actually isn't super interesting.
We've got a video uh which is basically
what people are watching. We've got a
video view or just a view that we can
talk about. That is when an individual
watched a video.
And then finally, we have a time window
or a duration that we're able to use to
query the API. The reason that we're
enumerating these nouns is because it's
useful to use in designing our API. But
this might seem overly simple because in
other problems like Ticketmaster, there
are more entities that you might need to
think through. It's still a useful
exercise even for an infra problem like
this to create these entities, but we
don't recommend you spend a bunch of
extra time here. Oftentimes, the
entities and APIs are a little bit more
straightforward for some of these
back-end systems than they are for full
products that you might need to design.
For my API, I need a way for my users to
be able to get the top K videos by view
for a given time period. I'm going to
use a REST API for this. It makes it
easy on my clients. It's very standard.
All interviewers are going to know about
it. And I'm going to query for
views  top K.
I'm going to pass in a window. I'm going
to pass in a K. And then I'm going to
have this return basically a video ID,
which is maybe a string, and then a
views count, which is probably an
integer. And it's going to be an array
of those. My clients will just assume
that this list is already sorted. And in
some sense, if I go back to my
functional requirements earlier,
I've got my top K most viewed videos.
I've got my top K most viewed videos for
last month. We can hour, that's going to
go in my window. And I've got my
tumbling windows. This is the only API
that I really need to create. So,
from this, I am done. You might be
asking yourself, do I need to include
pagination here? But remember that in
our requirements, we've already limited
K to 1,000. So, at worst case, this is
going to be a couple kilobytes. It's not
a big payload. You could add it if you
wanted to. You're not going to likely
create infrastructure around that
pagination just because it's such a
small number. But don't stress out if
you don't need it. The important thing
here is, and especially for more senior
candidates, I don't want to blow a bunch
of time on uninteresting parts of the
interview. My requirements were
interesting. I wanted to spend some time
there. I'm going to spend a lot of time
in my high-level design and deep dives.
But it necessarily means that I can
maybe skip a little bit of the time that
I would otherwise spend in my entities
or API for this particular problem. All
right, now that we've got my
requirements set, I've got my core
entities, I created an API. This is
functionally the contract that I need to
implement. We can move into our
high-level design. The high-level
design, remember, is about how we can
make the system functional, how we can
satisfy those functional requirements.
And we're going to do this as simply as
we can. We're going to kind of take some
shortcuts here and do some things that
are not scalable. And the reason for
that is we want a base that we can then
optimize and solve those problems in our
deep dives. So, that's what we're going
to do. For this particular problem, I am
going to take a shortcut, and it's one
that I would recommend that you do. And
I'm going to assume that there is a
video views topic sitting in Kafka
somewhere
uh put together by some other service on
YouTube. Note, for this problem, I'm not
being asked to design YouTube with a top
K feature. I'm only being asked to
design the the top K feature. And as
such, instead of making an API where I
would accept a view, I am just going to
assume that someone somewhere is keeping
track of those views in a Kafka topic.
This is a really good assumption. In a
lot of systems like this, you're going
to have topics that are recording some
of the most important events in your
system. And then systems can consume or
subscribe to those topics and then do
the things that they need to do. I'll
link in the description to our
event-driven architecture blog post. You
don't oftentimes see this show up in
system design interviews, but it is a
very popular way to design systems. And
having big granular topics with
important events can kind of be taken
for granted for a lot of systems. Now, I
want something that is going to consume
these views. So, I'm going to create a
service, I'll call view consumer, that's
going to read off that video view Kafka
topic. I could of course scale this out
if I need to. I'm going to assume these
video views are probably partitioned in
some way so that it's scalable.
Remember, we have a ton. We have
hundreds of thousands to millions of
views that are coming in every second.
So, this is going to become a bottleneck
very quickly. But let's pretend I have a
service that's reading from these. And
then I need to write it to a database
somewhere. So, let's go ahead and add a
views database. I'm going to use
Postgres for now because it's a
convenient way for me to get started,
and we'll try to decide where we might
hit some scaling limitations that might
make this intractable, but it should
definitely work for now. It'll be useful
for me to have some sort of table
structure where I'm going to store the
data here. I'm going to put my video ID,
and I'm going to put the number of views
in there. And with this, I've got a
really simple system that's going to be
keeping track of all of the video views
as they come in. Whenever a view
happens, my view consumer is just going
to update the record for that particular
video ID. It's either going to create a
new record with the view count being
one, or it's going to trigger an update
statement for a particular video ID, and
it's going to add one to the views.
And now I have in this video views table
the count of all views for all videos.
This is really useful. Now, we can start
to talk about what the read side of the
equation looks like. So, let's go ahead
and start with an API gateway just to
make things nice and standard. I'm going
to create a top K service, and that
service is going to make queries to my
views database. Since this is a SQL
database, I can actually trigger SQL
queries. So, let's talk about what that
SQL might look like. I'm going to do a
little copy-pasta here so we don't have
to see me type SQL. But what I'm going
to do is I'm going to select the video
ID and the corresponding views from my
video views table, and I'm going to
order by the views column. Finally, I'm
going to limit to my top K items. This
SQL query will actually get me the
all-time top K viewed video out of my
database assuming my data is structured
like this. Now, as a micro-optimization,
and I don't encourage you in the
high-level design to do lots of
optimization at this point, but it is
useful for you to be pointing out things
to your interviewer that might be
suboptimal either to address immediately
or as part of your deep dives. This
query is only going to be fast if I have
an index on views. And the reason for
that is otherwise, if I don't have this
index, what my database needs to do is
read every single row in the table,
and it needs to sort them all, and then
it will give me the top K. I think
Postgres might actually implement this
with a heap. I'm not sure. But
regardless, it's going to be
dramatically faster if I have this
index. The index on views is basically
like a sorted list.
And so, when we run this query, the
query planner is going to go look at
that index, and it's just going to go
grab the first K items off that list.
It's actually very fast. So, now we've
got a system that both writes our views
as they come in, and it reads them. Now,
some of you guys in the in the comments
are going to be puking right now. You're
going to say, "This isn't scalable. This
couldn't possibly work." I agree with
you. And I'm going to make notes of this
to my interviewer. I know that this
system doesn't scale. I'm going to start
with a basic system, and then I'm going
to optimize it as we go. If you are a
staff-level engineer, you probably don't
need to start with a system as basic as
this. You can skip some steps. And you
can trust that, you know, your
experience is going to be useful.
But if you are a more junior engineer,
then starting with a more basic solution
is going to yield dramatically better
results than if you try to jump straight
to an optimal solution. So, I would
highly recommend it. But with this, I've
solved my first requirement, and we can
move on to that next requirement. My
next requirement is to be able to
support those window queries. That's
where my user specifies they want to see
the last month. And with the system as
it stands, I can't answer those because
remember, my video views are summed over
all time. I can't distinguish the views
that happened last month from those that
happened last year. They're all bundled
together. And so, I need to make some
changes here. The simplest change that I
can make to this system is to add a
timestamp to this table. I still
probably don't want to record a row for
every view, although I could do that if
I wanted to make the most basic
high-level design possible. Instead,
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to round the time down to the nearest
hour. And this timestamp is going to
represent the beginning of the hour that
that view happened. So, I'm going to
have a bunch of buckets for every video
for each of the hours that they're
there. I'm not going to be able to use
the SQL that I had used previously. I'll
paste some more SQL in here. This is
probably going to be the query that I'll
use. And if you're not familiar with
SQL, that's totally okay. It is
important that you understand for
problems like this, how data is flowing
and what's happening. So, you need to be
able to reason about this conceptually.
If you haven't learned SQL before, I
highly recommend you learn it. It's
actually going to be very useful for you
as an engineer. But let me walk you
through what this means.
Basically, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to grab all of the records in this
table that fit within my window. So, I'm
going to choose the hours that fit
between the beginning of last month and
the end of last month. That way, I'm
only looking at views that have happened
over my window. The next thing is I'm
going to group these all together by the
video ID and then sum up those views.
I'm basically going to aggregate them so
I get a table of video ID to the total
number of views. And then finally, I'm
going to sort that table and then return
the top K elements out of it. The SQL
makes this seem really easy. And in some
sense, changing this SQL is is not too
hard. But where my previous SQL could
return very quickly by virtue of that
index that I had, I deliberately deleted
the index here because it's not really
going to help me all that much. I think
if I wanted to, I could add an index on
timestamp.
And then what that would do is just make
it so that way my query planner can
ignore rows that are outside the window
that I have. But for this query, I need
to read every single record in the table
that sits within that window. And I have
to do all the aggregation. So, this is
going to be dog slow. If the other
solution was sub-optimal, this is like
sub-sub-optimal.
And I'm probably going to note that to
my interviewer and say, "I realize
there's problems here. I'm going to get
to these in the deep dive." But
generally speaking, this system
satisfies my my requirement. I can query
for any of the windows that I have, last
month, last week, last day.
And I can get the top K value, even if
it's outside my non-functional
requirements of returning in
milliseconds. So, this gives me the base
to get into some of those deep dives
that we talked about. And that's what
we'll do next. In terms of optimizations
and deep dives, let's start with the
lowest hanging fruit first and then
we'll progressively get to the more
complex topics. This gives us the most
bang for the buck from an interviewing
perspective. We can impress our
interviewer with how quickly we were
able to move through things and save the
slow stuff that requires a lot of
brainpower for a little bit later. So,
the first thing that might stick out to
you all is on the read side. Right now,
the query takes a long time and our
promise to our users is that we would
return in milliseconds, tens of
milliseconds. And so, we are not
satisfying that non-functional
requirement. How can we make it happen?
Your brain should start to light up here
with two options, caching and
pre-computation. Let's talk about what
both of them would look like. So, for
caching, what this might be is we set up
a Redis cache over here. We can use a
read-through cache, so we can go and
query the Redis cache and see if we have
an entry for the top K query that we
have. The keys of the Redis cache might
be the time window, maybe some truncated
or rounded timestamp, and then the
values are basically the responses that
we're going to give to users.
If it's there, then we can return our
results to our users in single-digit
milliseconds, the gold standard. That
would be amazing. If we can't hit the
cache, if we have a cache miss, then we
need to go to the database and get the
actual value. Remember, this is going to
take forever right now, so this is a
very bad situation. But when we get
those results, we can simultaneously
return them to the user so that they get
them as fast as possible and write them
in the cache so that subsequent requests
are going to be much faster. As a
solution, this is pretty elegant, right?
We just added a cache and now say 99% of
our requests are going to be served in
single-digit milliseconds. Amazing. And
only a few of our requests are going to
end up hitting that database and then
taking minutes to hours of of time.
Maybe on average, we're actually in the
double-digit milliseconds, but this is a
pretty poor design overall.
With distributed systems, what you want
is consistency. The more predictable
things are, the more effectively you can
build on top of them. And this service
is Russian roulette. I might get a cache
hit. I get the best service I've ever
worked with. It
blazing fast. Or I might get the worst
service that I've ever touched. I'm
timing out. It's taking hours. What the
heck is going on? So, this is not a
particularly good situation because of
the cache misses.
But the nice thing about the cache
misses
is they're somewhat predictable. We know
that we are going to have a new last
hour every hour.
And so, we can anticipate when we're
going to have the cache need to be
refreshed.
And so, a better solution is probably
one where we actually do some
pre-computation. So, let's add a top K
cron service.
And this is going to every hour run that
query and populate the cache. Now, when
our top K service queries the cache,
we can hope that it's always there, that
we never have a cache miss even as the
hour expires. This is preferable because
you don't have a Russian roulette
scenario, but it does have some
downsides. What happens if this cron
fails? What do we do then? Well, a
terrible solution and and one that might
might come to mind is to have the top K
service hit the database then. So, if we
can't find it in the cache, we'll go get
it ourselves.
And the problem with this is this top K
cron is very infrequent. It's low load.
We're basically making one request an
hour or maybe a few requests an hour to
the database.
But when we have a failure here,
suddenly our top K service is making
thousands, maybe even millions of
requests to the database simultaneously
because they're all going, "Why do I not
have my cache entry? I'll go get it
myself."
So, we've amplified the load on the
database dramatically. If this cron was
failing because the database was
underload to begin with, we've made it
so much worse. So, we almost never want
to do something like this. What we might
do instead is to basically keep our
entries in our cache for a bit longer.
So, maybe we will store the window and
then some truncated timestamp as the key
in our Redis cache.
And we'll set the TTL to something long,
like, I don't know, 30 days. Now, when
our top K service queries the cache,
it's going to try to get the most
up-to-date information for the last
hour. But if it can't find it, it's just
going to fall back to the last window.
Now, this violates our SLAs, right? It
it means that we are not satisfying that
1-minute time between when an event
occurred and when it was tabulated, but
it's a better failure mode than the
alternative of tearing down our system
and making it really hard to bring back
up. So, it's a better option from that
perspective. So, overall, you can
probably improve the read performance
dramatically by simply pre-computing
with a cron that runs on predictable
intervals and stores information in a
cache. That's the easiest way to scale
and meet our read requirements. With the
read side partially solved, let's turn
our attention to the write side of the
equation, which is just a disaster in
the current design. I want to take a
step back to really put some numbers to
this problem so that we can think about
this more quantitatively. And I'll
caveat this a little bit. For Hello
Interview in general, what we find is
that a lot of candidates jump into
problems with a lot of
back-of-the-envelope estimations that
don't actually help them in their
design. And interviewers aren't looking
to see whether you can do mental
arithmetic as a condition of your
employment. If they are, they suck. You
shouldn't work for those companies. So,
generally speaking, what they do want to
see is how well justified are the
decisions that you're making. In this
case, I know that these writes are bad.
I know that there's billions of records
in here and that I've got way too much
load on this database, but I don't
really know how bad it is. So, let's try
to figure out how I might be able to
arrive at this. First, I might ask my
interviewer to give me some numbers.
Like, how many views are we expecting?
And maybe they tell me there's 70
billion views per day on the platform.
Generally speaking, when people are
designing systems, they're not usually
thinking about daily or yearly or hourly
quantities. They're mostly thinking
about, "What's the number of writes or
reads or transactions per second?" The
easy way to convert a views per day to
views per second is to divide by
100,000.
The actual number is 84 something. You
don't need that actual number. You are
doing mental arithmetic here. So, 70
billion over 100,000, well, that is
700,000
views per second. This is a really
useful quantity for me because it tells
me exactly how many writes I'm making to
my database currently. Remember, every
view is a write. So, I am triggering
700,000 writes per second. Um Postgres,
generally speaking, might be able to
handle 10,000 writes per second.
Probably not going to be able to handle
700,000 writes per second, especially if
we have more complicated indexing. There
are some certain conditions on which you
could support higher load on Postgres,
but this is just telling me, "Hey, I've
got a lot of writes here that I probably
can't handle." Another quantity that I
might want to know about is about about
the size of this table. I want to know
whether this data is becoming
insurmountably large. And the way that
I'm going to do that is I'm going to
start with the number of videos. Maybe
I'll make an assumption here, or maybe
my interviewer will tell me. Let's
assume they tell me that there are eight
not billion not views videos on the
platform. This is a lot. I would assume
most of those videos are never being
viewed. I'm going to multiply this by a
simple quantity. I'm going to say
there's eight bytes per video ID, and
then eight bytes for the views. That's
16 bytes. This is 64 for * 16
uh billion. I don't have a quantity
here. This is a billion. A billion is
also a gigabyte, so it's 64 GB for
storing a table of all video IDs and
their respective counts.
That number is pretty large. A lot of
engineers probably aren't working with
data sets that big on a regular basis.
But when it comes to data processing
systems, gigabytes are not that
impressive. In general, there are, you
know, multi-terabyte NVMe storage that,
you know, even a a run-of-the-mill
database would be able to support. So,
we don't have to be afraid of this
number in isolation. We do have to be
afraid of this number when it multiplies
out. And like, remember, with my design,
I am storing video views on an hourly
grain. So, I have one of these tables
every hour. So, 64 * 24, that's the
number of daily gigabytes that would
take. Now, do keep in mind that this is
a little bit more efficient because it
is what's known as sparse. My video
views are only being recorded when a
view actually happens. And the vast
majority of videos in this catalog are
getting zero views. They don't have any
rows in this table. So, this is a strong
upper bound on the size of each of these
basically partitions in my data. But it
does tell me that, "Hey, this is
somewhat manageable as long as I can
make sure that I'm not keeping too many
copies of this." So, now I've got two
quantities here. The 64 GB tells me a
bit about the storage, and then the 700K
tells me a bit about the throughput. So,
let's come back here to talk about our
writes. Well, our video views Kafka
topic could easily handle this 700,000
views per second. Kafka is very
scalable. These messages are only a
video ID and maybe a timestamp, so they
are tiny, and this can scale out
indefinitely. The way that this would be
scaled out is the video views topic
would be partitioned by video ID. So,
basically, if I was a consumer of the
video views topic, I would probably want
to choose a limited number of partitions
rather than swallowing the entire global
firehose and filtering down to the
videos I care about, I can actually only
read those video views that are going to
be important to me. That gives me a
chance to scale out my view consumer.
And when we think about write volume,
this should be our first instinct. We
should try to figure out how we can
partition or shard the inputs that are
coming in to us.
So, our video views topic is already
going to be partitioned by video ID.
Our view consumers can be partitioned by
video ID, so we'll have each view
consumer will handle a subset of those
video IDs. And then finally, we can
shard our Postgres database. We can have
it such that each instance only contains
the video views for a subset of those
video IDs.
I earlier gave you a number. I said
Postgres, generally speaking, can
handle, say, 10,000 writes per second.
This is a rough ballpark, but if we make
that assumption, we would need 70 shards
of Postgres and probably 70 view
consumers in order to consume this full
write volume. Now, that isn't without
its downsides. First of all, it's a ton
of resources, but it also means that
when we query, we need to query
separately each of the shards. Now,
fortunately, this is pretty basic
operation if we just want the top K most
viewed videos. What we can do is make
the same query to every shard. So, if we
want the top 1,000 most viewed, we're
going to say, "For each shard, shard
one, shard two, what is your top 1,000?"
And then we're going to merge them all
together to get the global top 1,000.
You can mathematically guarantee that
the global top 1,000 must be within all
the union of all of the local top top
1,000s. So, our query trivially scales.
Now, of course, it's not nice that our
cron job has to query 70 databases, but
arguably, that's going to be 70 times
faster than what it's currently doing
with a singular instance. And we already
have a lot of affordances that we've
developed here to allow this cron to
take additional time. Because one of the
things that you'll be worried about when
you're querying lots of shards like that
is some of those requests will probably
fail, and they'll need to be retried or
sent to a replica or something along
those lines. So, our first line of
defense for scaling out the right volume
in this problem in kind of the most
naive way is by partitioning and
sharding. After sharding and
partitioning, we have to get a little
bit more creative in order to improve
the performance of our system. In this
case, what we'll do is we'll work
through our scaling writes pattern,
which is basically a list of different
strategies that we can employ in order
to improve our rate efficiency. You can
find this on our website as part of the
premium offering, or I'll cover it here.
So, the next step for us in scaling
writes is for us to consider batching or
aggregation. Currently, every video view
means a write to our views database.
But our video views table is at the
hourly grade. So, we don't really care
about every write as it happens. We only
really care about the sum total of video
views over a tumbling window hour. So,
can we reduce the writes to our database
by aggregating or or pre-aggregating or
batching in our view consumer? Sure, we
can. So, what might that look like if we
don't use any technologies?
Well, what we could do in our view
consumer is we could keep a map in
memory of all of the views that we've
received and haven't flushed out to the
database. Then, every hour, what we can
do is write those into the database. And
in that sense, our problem is going to
largely go away. The number of writes
that we're going to make is now bounded
not by the number of views, where
700,000 times a second, but bounded by
the number of videos that had views in a
particular hour. You would expect that
number is a lot smaller. It is a problem
that we are waiting to do all of our
writes all at once at the end of the
hour. So, that means our database is
sitting around, it's chilling, and then
suddenly, it's slammed. But it's slammed
with substantially lower volume than
this constant streaming updates that we
are otherwise sending it. Now, if we do
this ourselves, the problems mount from
here. The first problem that we have is
failures. So, if this view consumer
fails
while it has an aggregate in memory,
you might wonder, do we lose those
views? It's obvious that the Kafka topic
will always be the source of truth. So,
as long as this Kafka topic has
retention,
then we can always have our view
consumer rewind in the Kafka topic and
then read from there to catch all the
views that it missed. So, even if we had
a view consumer fail, say, 45 minutes
into the hour, what it could do is then
start reading views from the beginning
of the hour, and then hopefully,
eventually catch up. That would be a
good recovery strategy. The problem with
that is that it requires a lot of scale.
If we set our view consumers and we
scale them such that they're able to
process 700,000 views per second, they
don't have any headroom to catch up.
Pretend I am that view consumer that's
45 minutes behind. I'm still processing
700,000 views per second cuz that's my
capacity, and I'm always going to be 45
minutes behind. I'm never going to catch
up. If we double the amount of capacity
that we have, so we have 1.4 million
views per second of view consumer
capacity, then that means that we are
able to work through 1 second of backlog
every 2 seconds because half of our
capacity will be taken up by just
staying up with the views as they come
in. And then the other half, the
remaining 700,000, allows us to start to
catch up.
And so that means if we are 45 minutes
behind, it's going to take us 45 minutes
to catch up. And that means that we are
definitely going to be late for the next
hour calculation. We're going to be 30
minutes late. So the problem with using
a Kafka topic with retention in order to
catch up after a failure, if we're
keeping really big windows like this, is
that it takes either too much capacity,
we need to multiply the view consumer
fleet so it has a lot of wasted
resources, or it's too slow to catch up.
The solution that we would implement is
to have some sort of checkpointing.
Maybe every 5 minutes, we write the sum
of views that we we have in that window
to S3. And then if our view consumer
fails, it can read the latest
checkpoint, so it can catch up to that 5
minutes, and then it can use the Kafka
view stream to catch up from there. So
we're no more than 5 minutes behind.
That strategy of checkpointing is so
common in streaming systems that they
built an entire framework around this,
and it is called Flink.
So in this problem, we could go and do a
bunch of aggregation in our view
consumers, or we could do the windows in
Flink. We'll say Flink hourly windows.
And what that looks like is we have a
Flink job that runs in a cluster. And
then Flink is going to handle our
checkpointing internally, and then Flink
is going to have special sources like
for Postgres or S3 or for Redis. And so
what's going to happen here is that
Flink will manage internally that
checkpointing, and then we'll write our
video views on the hourly grain as they
occur. Now, Flink is a funny technology
to trot out in interviews in part
because Flink is very powerful. A lot of
system designs can be expressed entirely
in Flink jobs, which is nice. You can
write a Flink job, which is just a lot
of Java code, deploy it to a cluster,
and then get rid of some or much of what
you see in this picture. The problem
with doing that in an interview setting
is that sometimes interviewers are not
familiar with Flink, so you might be
expressing a solution that they don't
understand, or they might feel like
you're oversimplifying the problem, or
maybe hiding all of the complexity
behind a technology. And then what
they're going to want you to do is to
explain how all the pieces work. Can you
explain to me Flink's checkpointing
algorithm, or can you explain to me how
tumbling windows work internally to
Flink? So I'll say in general, I would
use Flink sparingly in your interviews,
but many people are familiar with this
application of using Flink as an
aggregation platform basically for
streaming data. And so this is generally
a safe application for this problem.
And then what we've done here is we've
substantially reduced the number of
shards that we're going to need in our
views database in part because Flink is
taking the bulk of the load in
processing these views, and then
producing just the hourly grained
updates before we write it to our
database. Okay, so we're slowly chipping
away at this problem, and we've got our
read latency down much better, our write
throughput to the database has has
decreased. We still have a problem here
in that the cron is making these very
expensive database queries. And I want
to elaborate a bit on how expensive they
are, and then talk about how we can
start to to optimize this. So if we
think about our database queries, what
they're doing is they are grabbing all
of the video views across all of the
hours that are included in the window.
The pathological case that we need to
solve here is that we have an entire
month that we're trying to aggregate. So
we've got 24 * 30, 300 hours that we
need to pull.
And what we're going to have to do is
grab every row by hour, which is
probably going to be on the order of
hundreds of gigabytes of data. We have
some efficiency cuz this is sparse.
Remember, not all videos have views
every hour, so this isn't a full 64
gigabytes times that 300 number, but we
still have hundreds of gigabytes of
data. And then in our database, the next
step is they are going to aggregate by
video. So for each video, we're going to
get all of the hours, and we're going to
sum those up. So now we've got total.
This is probably going to be tens of
gigabytes. Most of our videos are going
to have views over the month. We should
expect that this is less sparse, and
this is not sorted in any way. These are
just aggregates. And then finally, we
have to go and sort this. And the sorted
value, especially if we take it down to
just the top K, is just kilobytes of
data. Like our output is not that big,
but we are processing an enormous amount
of data in order to get there. And like
I said, whenever we are processing an
enormous amount of data, this should be
a cause for pause. Now,
a lot of people will think, I've got an
enormous amount of data, that sounds
like a place where I should use Spark or
Hadoop. And I think the instinct there
is probably a good one. What Spark or
Hadoop allows you to do is to scale out
this computation. This is
parallelizable.
If I wanted to, I could have
an individual machine for every video
that adds across all of the hours.
And then in the the sorting, what I can
do is have each machine sort a subset of
the data.
And then they can pull that data
together, and then merge sorted lists.
That's known as a reduce operation in in
Hadoop. And while that does allow us to
scale this out, it doesn't make this any
more efficient. We're still throwing an
enormous amount of resources and
hardware at a problem that we can
probably think more deeply about in
order to solve. So what what can we do
here? Well, one thing to note is that
our hourly windows are landing in the
database, but we end up wanting to
aggregate these. And so one thing we
might ask ourselves is is there a way
for us to have our day, month video
views? Now, whenever Flink is doing the
processing at the hourly grain,
it's going to update not just one
record, the hour record with the
timestamp and the total views.
It's also going to increase all of the
views for the day and the month that
that hour is a part of. So it will 3x
the number of writes that we will do
into our database, but now when we want
to do our reads, we can actually read
directly out of these tables. So we're
saving a bunch of resources. I think
this is a much more elegant solution
than doing all of this aggregation
um on the flip side. And one thing that
it allows us to do is it allows us to
index on timestamp and on views.
Remember when we had our all-time
queries.
Because we had the index on views and
there was no timestamp, we basically had
a sorted list of video ID by views, and
our query planner could just grab the
top K elements off that list. It was
really fast and efficient. With this
setup, we get the same thing because at
a given timestamp, we are going to be
sorted by views. So all we need to do,
and this is basically a B-tree
operation, we're going to grab out of
the sorted list by timestamp and by
views the top viewed items for that
timestamp for that granularity. So now
our top cron is running effectively in,
you know, a constant time or near
constant time operation rather than
needing to do a bunch of aggregation and
sorting. Now some people might be saying
to themselves, okay, well Flink is
already doing these aggregations, why
don't we just have Flink do it? Can't
Flink just make hourly, daily, monthly
windows? Then instead of needing to do
some sort of aggregation over here, we
can just land those as they're ready. In
fact, if you've got those hourly, daily,
monthly windows, you can also have a
Flink operator that goes and sorts them
and then returns the top K.
And that is a potential option. You
could have Flink output directly to this
Redis cache, in some sense obviating
both the cron and Postgres. The reason
that I don't think that this is a great
option for interviews in general is that
interviewers don't want to turn this
into one big giant Flink box. If they
do, they probably want you to go into
detail about each of the operators in
each of the jobs. And I don't know about
your preparation, but if you want to
make it very Flink-centric, maybe
getting up to speed there is a gamble
you want to take. But, it's probably not
the right trade-off for most people in
their preparation, but it's something
that you could potentially do here. Just
going to make a quick note and an edit
here that you'll likely want to include
a table that has the video views all
time and keep that, much like your
hourly, daily, and monthly. You'll be
adding to this as well. It won't have
any timestamps, but this also can
include an index on views and be
queryable whenever we want to answer
questions related to that first
functional requirement. So, if there was
any confusion, yes, we'll keep that
table. With that, we've reached the end
of what I would consider the core of
this particular solution. We've got an
optimized read path that returns in
double-digit milliseconds. We have a
write path that is properly sharded and
partitioned that pre-aggregates data and
indexes it in a sensible way so that
queries can be answered quickly and
users get the results they're expecting.
For a junior through senior candidate, I
think if you hit many of the points
here, you're in a pretty good spot as it
pertains to the interview that I just
described. For staff-level candidates,
there's a lot more that we could
potentially discuss here. We can change
the rules a bit. Well, what if we need
to support more windows or topics?
What if we need to support sliding
windows? Those are all fair game for
staff-level interviews. Another thing
that staff-level candidates will
oftentimes go into is how do some of
these things work in particularly ugly
scenarios. The views database is
sharded. What if I have all of the views
for a particular timestamp for one shard
but not another shard? How do I detect
that downstream and how do I make sure
that my clients understand the results?
Some of these things can get a little
bit dicey, but they're also very
detailed, and so it's actually difficult
to formulate the problem until you're
actually in the weeds. But, staff-level
candidates will oftentimes notice
problems like that. Problems like how do
we handle out of order events? Or how do
we think about timestamping the events
as they enter our aggregation? These are
all pretty rich topics. Now, each
interview is going to be different. And
as I mentioned, interviewers might
change the requirements on you, or they
might just give you a different set of
requirements to start with. I wanted to
spend some additional time in this video
talking about a few variants just to
give you an idea and a starting point
for how you might address these pieces.
I want you to keep in mind that your job
as a candidate is not to memorize every
possible answer to a top K problem. It's
to internalize some of the lessons that
we've walked through around aggregation
and batching and caching so that when
you have a new requirement, you can
address it on the fly. Interviewers are
not expecting you to invent novel
algorithms. They are expecting you to
have a very solid grasp on the basics so
that you can adapt, and they want to see
your thinking through the process.
Everybody's going to come up with a
different solution, and that's okay.
There's not one right answer to this
problem. It's way more important that
you show how you work through it. Now,
one of the earlier things that we did in
requirements for this problem is that we
forced our way into a tumbling window.
Tumbling windows are much simpler for us
to deal with. Remember that tumbling
windows mean that we are centering our
last hour at the beginning of the hour.
With a sliding window, we're going to
keep moving that window forward as time
progresses. And usually, there's a
notion of how often that window is
moving. You could do this continuously,
that would be a little bit crazy, or you
could do this once every minute. And
what that means is that functionally,
you have more windows to deal with. If
you move it every minute, then with a
tumbling window, you have one window
every hour.
With a sliding window, you have 60
windows every hour.
And this gets only more perverse if you
think about sliding windows over monthly
periods, so on and so forth. So, how can
we start to think about sliding windows
in a way that is tractable and doesn't
require us to boil the ocean in terms of
storage and memory? Well, one way to
look at this is to think about how we
can actually come up with a value of the
total number of views in a sliding
window. If we wanted at time 60 to find
out the total number of views in the
last hour,
we would go over every minute in that
hour, and then we would sum the total
number of views. I'm not even going to
do the math here, but add all these
numbers together, and that is the
quantity for the last hour at time 60.
At time 61,
we will have one new minute of views.
So, maybe we added six new views in that
minute. Additionally, some of those
views happened now more than 60 minutes
ago. At minute 61, the very first minute
are no longer in our window. So, if we
think about how a sliding window works,
what's happening is we can take the last
window,
we can add the most recent minute and
subtract the minute that happened 61
minutes ago. What that will give us is a
change. So, we have a plus six, minus
five, and that means that we've added
one. This isn't actually all that
complicated, and knowing this, this
intuition, we can start to think about
how our design might need to be adjusted
to facilitate sliding windows.
So, let's try to walk through that.
Currently, we are aggregating at an
hourly level.
If we want to do sliding windows that
move every minute, we're probably going
to need minute grain data. So, let's go
ahead and get that. Now, we need to
store this data because we need to have
these minutes available.
So, let's go ahead and move our video
views table, and we will have a video
views
minute table that has a video ID, views,
and a timestamp. Instead of having our
video views for an arbitrary hour, day,
or month, how about we make this the
last hour, day, or month and get rid of
the timestamp entirely? This is just
going to be the current value of the
sliding window.
Same thing with video views all time,
but we're only adding to this. Now, we
can change our index to only be on
views. So, what would we do here?
Well, when the video views come in,
we're going to have Flink aggregate them
per video into a video ID and a view
count for that minute. At the end of the
minute, Flink is going to flush this to
our views database. So, we're going to
immediately write it to this video views
minute table, all of the values. Now, we
need to update our sliding windows. What
are we going to do there? Well, what
we're going to do is if we want to
update the hour,
we're going to grab the minute that
happened 61 minutes ago.
We're going to get all those views,
and we're going to subtract that value.
The minute that we just added, we're
going to add. So, we'll take whatever
we're going to add minus the videos that
need to be decremented, and then we will
add the difference to our sliding
window. That will update this table,
including the index. And now, when our
top cron needs to make this call, it's
going to be able to query those tables.
Now, our top cron can no longer run once
an hour. Our top cron actually has to
run more frequently. It has to run every
minute. And our cache needs to not only
have the truncated timestamp per hour,
it needs to have basically the minute of
that timestamp. So, this is going to run
more frequently, but this is super
efficient. Remember,
since we have these tables already
sorted by views, all we have to do is
grab the top item, and we already have
an index or top K items off this, and we
already have the index here. So,
you know, functionally, the data is
already ready. Now, what this does is it
increases the amount of writes that
we're going to need to do, and we're
making reads from the database, which is
a little bit unusual. We're basically
using this as state for our system. But,
that would be one solution that you
could use to implement sliding windows
in a system like this while retaining
all of the performance characteristics
that we talked about. Now, like all of
our other solutions, there are ways that
you could do this in in Flink as well.
We could use Flink sliding windows.
Flink has both tumbling windows and
sliding windows.
And the way that this works is that
Flink will create a new window every
interval. This is called the window
slide. We've been talking about a window
slide of 1 minute. So, we will create a
new month-long window every minute, and
that window will be a month long. It
will continue to accumulate over that
time. If you're grimacing right now,
you're thinking about this correctly
because what this is doing is it's
multiplying the number of windows that
we need to maintain by the number of
minutes in a month. So, we could
externalize the storage to something
like S3 or Rocks. There's a lot of ways
that we could try to optimize this Flink
job, but these sliding windows,
especially with the slide that we're
talking about, are not going to be very
efficient. Now, that's not to say that
you can't build the solution that I just
described natively in Flink. You could
keep as state these minute-level views
externally, and then have those recorded
and checkpointed alongside the Flink
jobs. It's entirely possible for you to
wrap this in up in a Flink job. I am
saying that Flink's native sliding
windows will be quite inefficient at
this task. I'm going to make one more
note on the sliding window solution
that, generally speaking, sliding
windows that are a month long probably
don't make sense from a product
perspective. It's always a bit dicey as
a candidate to try to push back on
requirements from an interviewer. So, if
they tell you you need a sliding window
at a month, you probably need to figure
out how to make it happen. But, if they
haven't explicitly stated that, it might
be a good idea for you to show some
judgment and say, "We probably don't
need sliding windows at this
granularity." Sliding windows at an hour
might make sense, but at a month, maybe
a tumbling window is fine. Those videos
aren't going to change very much anyway,
and so people aren't expecting that
they're going to shift every minute. For
you, I think being able to show the
trade-offs and and what would be
required, being able to say, "Here is
the additional infrastructure or here is
the additional memory that's required to
make this feature." And then being able
to say, "Well, we can dial this back for
our higher windows, and then we can keep
it granular at lower windows." Is
oftentimes a nice set of trade-offs that
really shows engineering maturity, and
then oftentimes something that I hear
from candidates at higher levels. The
last variant that I want to cover is if
we relax that requirement to have a
precise result. If we wanted to have an
approximate solution to the problem.
Well, why might we want to do this?
Well, top K, we have to think about the
applications. For YouTube, this is
probably supporting some of their
trending applications. Maybe it's a
signal into their recommendation system
as a candidate generator, but in a lot
of cases, it's going to be secondary to
the core video playing and advertising
experience. Google is going to want to
make this inexpensive to run. They don't
want to throw a tremendous amount of
hardware getting the exact right top K
results if they can do it much more
affordably with an approximation. A good
rule of thumb to ask yourself as an
engineer, and then also for design
interviews, is who's going to notice if
the answers are wrong, and then do they
care? And I think the answer for YouTube
top K is probably not. In this case, I
think approximations are a good option.
Now, for an interview setting, I don't
know that jumping into an approximation
solution is a good idea from a strategic
perspective cuz they tend to be more
complicated, but it it is a a
potentially good idea that, you know, if
you've got extra time and you want to
showcase to your interviewer, this would
be one way to do it. Now, to to to kind
of walk you through this, I want to talk
about where we would use approximation
in this solution. You'll note that the
really expensive part of this problem
comes in our views database, where we're
retaining these relatively large tables
of video views and their timestamps.
And the the challenge here is that this
could potentially get somewhat large. We
aren't going to retain these
indefinitely, so we would probably start
to expire rows as their timestamps uh
became old. And remember that we are
basically upper bounded by 64 gigs. So,
when you start to talk about counts and
approximation, I want you to hear
count-min sketch in the back of your
head. Count-min sketch is an
approximation algorithm. You can think
of it kind of like a Bloom filter, but
for counts. And it's a way to really
efficiently do two things. One is
count-min sketch will remember things
that it's seen, so you will pass it
identifiers. They can be numbers or
strings. And then you can query the
count-min sketch given an identifier and
get an estimate for how many times it's
seen it before with some known error
bounds on it. The core idea of count-min
sketch is it functions a lot like this
hash table that allows us to retrieve
the number of views for a video ID, but
with substantially less space, and then
obviously some error that we're going to
throw on top. So, let me show you what
this looks like using a little simulator
that was put together by someone in our
comments. I'm actually pretty impressed
by this. I will note that this is a
little confusing because we are using
lots of different types of hashes here,
which is not really how count-min sketch
works. Usually, each of these hashes
would actually just be a salt. You might
even use the same hash and then just use
different bits of it. But, the core idea
is that each of these hash functions is
going to take as input whatever we want
to pass in, the identifier, and then
it's going to give us an index based on
the width of our sketch. So, in this
case, I have eight columns in my sketch.
I am going to, if I want to add
something to my sketch and have it
remember it, so "foo", what's going to
happen is we are going to take each of
these hash functions, apply them to that
input, and then the output will be the
index that we should increment. So, look
what happened here. I added "foo". For
this first row, this hash function
outputted, I guess this would be zero or
seven, depending upon how you want to
look at it, and then we incremented the
counter at that index. Same thing for
each of these subsequent hashes. So,
what I've basically got is my sketch was
changed by the input of "foo". If I
added "foo" again, the hash of "foo"
hasn't changed. And so, what you'll see
is that each of the indexes is the same,
each of those numbers is going to be
incremented to the same value, and so
I'm going to basically see all those
ones become twos. Now, if I wanted to
add "bar" to my sketch,
it's going to increment different
indexes.
In some of those cases, those might be
overlapping, like "foo" and "bar" both
have the same hash under this city hash,
so that's now three. But, basically, we
now have this set of counters,
and we have incremented at the index of
the hash of the ID for both "foo" and
"bar" into that. So, that's how we add
items to a sketch.
Now, when we want to query the sketch,
we can ask it, "How many times have you
seen this thing before?" So, maybe I'm
going to put "hello" here. And then what
it's going to do is going to hash
"hello" and it's going to look at the
indexes of the hash function, um and
it's going to grab the value there. And
then it's going to grab the value from
each of these rows, whatever it happens
to be,
and it will take the minimum of those.
So, you can see in dark blue, we'll hit
it a few times, those are the cells that
it's querying, and the minimum of those
cells is zero.
Which means that I've never incremented
"hello" into the sketch. If I wanted to
query "foo", I would get
two, because the minimum of all of those
cells
at the indexes that those hash functions
coincide to is two. The problem that we
have is these collisions. Right here, we
have some cells that are three. And so,
the worst-case scenario would be that we
grab those cells and we assume that
"foo" is actually three. But, how would
that happen? It would require that we
have collisions on all of the cells that
"foo" has occupied. And the probability
of the collision is based on the number
of hashes. This is the the height of the
sketch, and the width of the sketch, the
number of columns.
So, basically, count-min sketch allows
me to remember various identifiers,
maybe video IDs for our problem.
And then we can query those identifiers
and then retrieve an approximation,
actually a an upper bound on the count
that it has been added to the sketch.
Okay, cool. We've got count-min sketch.
It allows us to keep track and remember
the counts of things. But, how do we
query the sketch for the top K items? We
can't actually just go to the sketch
values and then divine what items were
in it. In some sense, the sketch forgets
the identifiers. It just remembers their
imprints. And so, we have to be clever
and pair this sketch with something more
traditional, like a sorted list. So, a
typical process would be like this.
When a view comes in, we will add the
count to the sketch for that identifier.
That will increment all of those
indexes, so that way we can query them
later. We are immediately after we add,
we're going to query the sketch for the
approximate count for that item. Because
we at that moment, we remember the
identifier. That thing did get a view at
that moment, and so it is a potential
candidate for our top K. So, we're going
to query its value and return that here.
So, maybe we have video one has actually
been seen a thousand times now. At that
point, we will go and update a sorted
list or a heap. And the idea is this
sorted list doesn't need to be all 4
billion videos. This might be just a few
thousand videos.
But, in general, what we're expecting is
that this sorted list will get updated
every time something important happens.
And so, the sorted list, we can
basically restrict those updates to only
view counts that are greater than the
bottom of the list. We don't really care
about view counts on items that are way
below the the top K. They don't matter
to us until they reach that threshold
where they're actually in the running
for the top K. So, in practice, what you
might do is you might use something like
Redis for this. Redis has two data
structures. It has native support for
count-min sketch. So, you would use the
cms.incrby
in order to add I think it has a query
command. I forget exactly what it's
named. And then, each view, the view
consumer would grab the ID, it would
increment, it would read that value,
then it would check to see if it was
greater than the lowest number in the
sorted set. And then, it would add that
item or update that item into the sorted
set. When our users come in and they
want to query the top K, they'll go to
the Redis cache, they will query those
values, and they will return them back
to the user. Now, of course, using a
volatile store like Redis for this, it
we have data loss potential. So, you
would want to consider how you maintain
replicas, how you use append-only file,
and other pieces there. This gets a
little bit hairy because when we add an
item to a Redis cache, if Redis cache
crashes and we have to restore it, it's
difficult for us to know whether that
item was added in what what we have in
our backup, basically what we can
restore from the append-only file. But,
remember, this is an approximation. So,
like, if the system introduces some
error, it's not mathematically optimal,
but it's probably not breaking the bank
in terms of the outputs to our users.
Remember, they may not be able to
validate this. Now, another option for
us is to put the count-min sketch inside
of Flink. Basically, we would have the
sketch be part of the state that Flink
manages. It would checkpoint that state
and keep it externally. The sorted sets
and heap would basically be in memory.
They would be persisted durably so that
they can recover. But, this would
actually be probably a more rugged
option for us. And then, periodically,
Flink would flush that out to something
like Redis so that it could be read by
our top K service and returned via an
API gateway. Again, the Flink solution
here kind of feels hand-wavy, right? It
Interviewers are going to want to go
into a lot more detail about that. But,
it has this nice property of doing this
all in memory. And that means it can be
lightning fast. Like, if our goal is to
minimize the amount of hardware that we
use for this problem, that is probably
one of the best solutions that we can
employ. Now, so far, we've talked about
what this looks like for tumbling
windows where we're only adding. I want
to make a couple notes here.
Count-min sketch if you go read the
Wikipedia page, you're going to see that
you can add and query, there's no
subtract operation. And that's partly
true.
If you have what are called turnstile
operations where you are only removing
things that you had previously added,
then you can guarantee a lot of the same
properties. If you look on the article,
we have some links to references that
explain what this looks like. And so, if
you wanted to do this with a sliding
window, you would do much the same thing
that we did earlier. You would basically
add views as they happen, and then, you
would remove them 60 minutes later or 1
month later. You could do that by having
a separate consumer group that reads off
of the Kafka topic, or you could
potentially have Flink retain all of
that in state. That seems a little bit
duplicative, but you would basically add
and remove items so that the sketch
represents the sliding window.
And then, the sorted list or heap needs
to be sized accordingly. We need to have
some buffer so that way items that are
low and then might be gaining into the
top K when other items fall out of the
top K as in they are decremented. But,
you might use a sorted list or a heap of
size like 5,000, and you're likely going
to cover all of the scenarios that you
might care about. Of course, there is
mathematically a scenario where 5,000
isn't enough. But, remember, this is
also an approximation. So, we kind of
don't care about those situations that A
are never going to happen, but B only
affect our result in these very edge
case scenarios. So, this would be an
example of a highly optimized
approximate system. I think if
interviewers are looking for this
solution, they're basically looking for
whether you've studied this problem
before, and I don't think it's a
particularly good interview question.
So, if you get one where the interviewer
was expecting this, I apologize. I think
it's esoteric. But, I hope that this was
interesting for you as you think about
how you might design systems at even
higher scale. I would not probably
recommend starting with an approximate
solution in an arbitrary interview for
the one risk that the interviewer may
not actually understand a lot of what
we're talking about here. That is a real
risk that we've seen from some of our
users in comments where their
interviewers just don't quite get it.
And yeah, it it it can happen. So, be
careful and try to veer toward simpler,
more proven solutions like we talked
about earlier on in this video.
Before we wrap up, I wanted to give some
commentary on some specialized databases
that people are commonly asking about
for these problems. The specialized
databases have some downsides that I
think make them disfavorably for using
in an interview setting. The worst-case
scenario is your interviewer is just not
familiar with the technology that you're
bringing to the table. And they've got
two options there. Either A, they say,
"Use something else." I'm pretend like
that doesn't exist, in which case all of
your knowledge goes out the window, or
they ask you to explain it at a much
finer granularity. They basically want
you to explain the internals of whatever
database you're using. In which case, if
you've got that knowledge and you've
been working with it for a while,
fantastic. But, a lot of times that's
going to sound a lot like the general
solutions that we've been talking about
where, instead of talking about
hypertables and continuous aggregates in
timescale, we're talking about, you
know, how we do pre-aggregation and then
how we query it from our database.
It's just easier in most cases for you,
if you're preparing for interviews, to
think about solutions that work with
simpler technology stacks than ones that
work with very specialized technology.
And I know somebody in the comments will
say, "No, none of this is very
specialized." Agree to disagree. In
terms of the options here, I've got a
few opinions. Timescale is an extension
on Postgres. They basically take the
table metaphor and they call it
hypertables. They're basically tables
with time series, which is more
efficient for both storing and
retrieving time series data. And then,
they add some additional capabilities on
top of that, like continuous aggregates.
The continuous aggregates basically
generates new tables with aggregated
data as the data is coming in, which is
really cool for our purposes because
those generated tables can have indexes
on them, which means that we can have
continuous aggregates for our tumbling
windows with indexes on the aggregate
views. So, we can make the querying
really efficient. In some sense, this
being built on Postgres saves it from
the problems that other time series
databases might have. Now, in the like
more strict time series database, we've
got Prometheus. I spell that right?
Yeah. And InfluxDB. Prometheus is used
in a lot of observability stacks. If you
use Datadog or New Relic or Grafana,
you've probably either used Prometheus
directly or used something like it.
These are specialized and they're
intended to basically support a single
screen graph. It's like we want data
points over time for one series. And the
capabilities there are really good. You
can upsample and downsample. The problem
comes when you want to look across
screens, across graphs, across series,
or in Prometheus language, across
labels.
If we want to do a top K query, we want
to go and take all of the series for
each of the videos, and then, we want to
sort them. And these databases aren't
going to help us out at all in that
process. So, we're going to have to
query the database a billion times for
each of the series and then sort it
externally. And at that point, you're
kind of like, "Well, what is this doing
for me?" There are probably some I think
suboptimal solutions using some of the
techniques that we talked about earlier
where you can cache or, you know, run
some preprocessing. But, in general, I
don't think they fit this problem quite
as elegantly as some of the
alternatives. So, I would shy away from
using these. The final category are what
I would call like real-time OLAP or
streaming OLAP solutions, Druid, Pinot.
Pinot? ClickHouse. Generally speaking,
these are going to provide some variant
of materialized views that allow us to
do that aggregation internal to the
database.
So, like Flink has subsumed a lot of the
challenges of streaming frameworks
around checkpointing and state
management, these OLAP databases have
subsumed a lot of the problems that are
associated with streaming analytics use
cases. That is both good and bad. It's a
blessing and a curse for this problem in
that it's kind of makes it trivial. It's
just a configuration that you would have
on some of the input. And as a result,
there's just not a whole lot to talk
about in an interview setting. It's also
very likely that your interviewer is not
familiar with all three, maybe even some
of them. So, you know, same caveats
apply. I if I was preparing from
scratch, I would not spend a lot of time
trying to memorize or understand some of
these more specialized databases or
frameworks. Instead, I would invest my
time in really trying to understand data
flow, some of the core patterns around
aggregation, catch, caching, etc. And
then what you'll find is that those
things are going to basically be
implemented in some of these
technologies. You'll give yourself a leg
up in understanding why the tech exists
and then how it works under the covers
so that you're ready to go when the
interview happens. All right, folks, we
have covered a lot of ground in this
breakdown. We've covered stream
processing, approximation techniques,
count-min sketch, time series databases,
the works. I hope this was useful for
you. I think if you're at the end of
this video and you're going, "Wow, some
of that was overwhelming." I want to
you know, let you know that yeah, some
of it was probably beyond what you'll
need in an interview setting. So, go
back to some of those core deep dives if
you're really looking to say, "All
right, what do I actually need to be
ready?" But, I want to encourage you
that understanding how data flows
through a system is the unlock for
infra-style interviews. And if you can
get a handle on how big are the tables
and where are they flowing and when is
the compute happening sooner or later
and what does the caching look like,
you're going to be able to solve a lot
more problems than if you just try to
memorize solutions and parrot them out
in an interview setting. Please hit up
the comments if you've got questions or
suggestions. The article that we have
linked will probably have more
up-to-date updates as we go just because
the video will be fixed, but we really
appreciate your time and hope this was
useful. Till next time.